okay baby is episode three unperson
that's a pretty good game actually it
just pretty uh what sighs anyone let's
say okay continue
I've got a public one and a care file
member okay we gotta fund all about Nina
let's say listener
I know person Harrison Harrison's dating
Juliet oh he's definitely cheating on
Juliet as Nina okay okay excuse me
yeah okay we're gonna find out what you
want Jesus times like hey like take it
easy okay so here something like tons of
people at once
um Jesus okay
concerned one that's Nina I think right
wait I just Nina or is that Juliet
let's say here Tubman yeah I guess yeah
why is the the safety bill I think is
what the safety bills like is all real
thing we're doing okay okay so we're
girls
he doesn't like violence that's fine you
know everybody doesn't have to like
everything you know Jesus I like in the
picture Nina
[Music]
makin apologize all hey watts but you
know Jays us okay I just I feel like I
should look at this what am I missing
here nothing Jesus Stelling you watch
airs on a Donnell help great shadows oh
no it's on hold indefinitely was that
dead okay I guess we'll never know I
guess on that right now listening oh my
god her that definitely [ __ ] her
wearing that whoever that is holy [ __ ]
what's going on nice house on Saturday
[Music]
okay so he's talking to marca the
[ __ ] market Nima's again saying okay
Harrison is I gonna pleasures it but I
guess he is am I guess he's freaking
what do you call that thing a band
member so you know they start again
headlines but what am I missing here
what am I missing here that 50 shades of
grey nonsense something no I'm missing
something here
ooh I gotcha
we can listen on or now hello and then
she'll Sylvia so yeah
what if like Symes is the criminal you
know well that's up here it's Saturday
so what's going on Saturday depressed
[Music]
come on have a little faster bro okay I
can try with her hey Nina man yeah just
kind of work now any work why do you
work Bevin okay I just need that now
okay see you go and cheer up anyway
let's go check out her dating profile
singular don't be single be singular
what does that [ __ ] man
oh so that's her six foot one holy [ __ ]
she looking for man that's fine it is
happening say I need this
[Music]
recent profile visitors and me
[Music]
she want that money baby sad can you
like let me do my job like ass are we
partners or something or like what like
why does he like criticizing everything
I do like can I just examine my own [ __ ]
like you know like Jesus right under hey
every one day
she goes behind my lease which sometimes
[Music]
that's true
[Music]
now you'd be surprised batch
everything's so like oh [ __ ] this is a
much better picture she's got a man
that's a man audience what is this okay
can email can I just like look her up on
the database like why do we have to like
dig for all this [ __ ] hmm
[Music]
what it's just some foreigner this brown
rubber plants i i'm not telling the
politics okay
germination results an enum met anova
she died just take like 10 hours
[Music]
okay
now insurance [ __ ] happening here
not like a
[Music]
[ __ ] is that
[Music]
could you talk ago
[Music]
psychopath another person
okay what do you want
he really digs out huh
[Music]
huh what the [ __ ]
had she typed that surface and swirling
your land that'd be cool
I said I want to head back to old math
way in you okay that's not like someone
you need the help okay okay chase us the
hacker bro
it is a hacker
[Music]
that's gonna need hay in a hurry I
thought what the [ __ ] this work sounds
crazy how was it it's gotten so fast
well so hacking the same time like
chains us that's what I'd like
severe weather whining Jesus my name is
Niall keeps calling me Orlando but it's
now you my cell phone around here
somewhere now or what I don't think
anyone else knows either cuz you would
tell me my phone went this is so sad
chicken
[Music]
okay it's gonna find Harrison we gotta
get them all right Anna its eyebrow man
this person is slow typing you know Anna
does our best finally yeah how did
pretty good things I got here
what is this you just check to say that
anything that's off between occasions
let's check its reader real quick
anything that change Oh previous entry
how much going insane never get a hit
[Music]
okay
[Music]
I can't
[Music]
I don't know about that
[Music]
okay insider let's check that out PC but
tonight rash oh [ __ ] okay how'd it go
back there we go oh we got her number I
mapping but I thought we already had
that [ __ ]
how do i how do I [ __ ] it back
housekeeping up there's this boy cry bat
Gopal's holy [ __ ] man this guy lured
truck through raised you like a
recruiter
[Music]
do I wish you this one no okay I get
back I'm antenna right
it's a michael squad
oh hello shoot shoot I record on now
you
one sideways like a dating thing what's
up there kids crazy
[Music]
Hey
[Music]
Stephen Schwartz whereas a history
[Music]
I go back the [ __ ]
[Music]
okay hello [ __ ] this is way too much
stuff here did
hey baby welcome to Rosen to get colored
outside of our office hours baby you're
a little Joel bug okay sister is that
like real though it's getting crazy
it's cantorial cries ain't no better one
of my not sure I should looks like come
on bro
Brett come on you're gonna talk a lot
faster you had a rough style well don't
we all have a rough start sometime ok ok
let's say uh yes that's good that's kind
of thank you
hey I have two can come on hurry up a
little bit you talk a lot slow ok let's
just talk a little slow dude Sam
seriously bro like can you just let me
do my work like dude do you like
secretly always want my job or something
like what's going on here come on bro
big sister
my guys gonna let's get this [ __ ] holy
[ __ ] she's badass comment is in here
[ __ ]
it was sucking her yes I can
[Music]
[Music]
nice shot
Shanta pasting [ __ ]
[Music]
you
you
[Music]
okay how many [ __ ] Russians you down
[Music]
I get his going down right I mean the
yellow thorough here so that's how you
feel take so slow so how they're talking
okay plucking more out did I mess up in
here now he's a dead people and I didn't
hear oh my god
Jesus live and died no wonder she won a
well
[Music]
she can't get a job
no one knows she's crazy
[Music]
last week in bed is that real
[Music]
you
[Music]
chased an she's done my god
[Music]
[Music]
did Harrison's like soap at what a
computer just crash right the need is
that he was going to turn it off
personally yeah
you
sound sound chases they got us
they got us
sounding people oh yeah the pants guy
very interesting very interesting so
much going on that did how much I've had
sex times just like again trying to get
my job you know baby okay okay um oh
okay that's too thick thank you miss I
love chicken oh no oh my god has just
been off the Hojo
[Music]
[Music]
what the [ __ ] okay just to recap we got
a lot of evidence about Nina okay we got
a lot of evidence about Nina it's very
sad for a lesson egg
now he knows are at work I said [ __ ] I
better grab him
is it gone that great day right over
well orwellian you know trash change ass
you know if you got the Sun so she's
going to the orchard place make another
shop there we're gonna get her she's
done I'm gonna have my phone ringing
somewhere oh the fun still active
there's a long table as well
still active right who's talking nobody
she's about to get arrested
what guy oh man they're gonna get the
this is interesting
she's going in guns blazing oh now
exciting Nana at another tap worker
they got her together since dawn Wow
[Music]
ah so girl found sense in job long I
know I hate that
[Music]
all right what's it I just shine out
that word I didn't buy the mic a little
time but it's okay thank you bye-bye
thank ya